so it's great to have you in our 50 over
50 list
thank you for having me my pleasure to
be here with you
so i'm curious because i i feel like
this list is actually
it's celebrating women over 50 60 70
80 having such power and having such
impact
but the message really is for younger
women absolutely and i'm wondering as a
younger woman um maybe
you at 20 or 25 did you ever imagine
your career after 50.
never i thought i was going to continue
being on television
and having my own show but i never i
really never thought what was going to
happen after
50 and that at 59 i was going to be able
to
be where i'm at when you were younger
when you did you plan your career or try
to plan it in your mind or imagine it
i always wanted to be a journalist right
and i did that for 35 years and i was
enchanted
i was in love with my career in in your
20s did you think oh when i'm 55 i'm
going to be doing this in my career i'm
going to be
were you even imagining a career in your
50s i knew i was going to stay on
television
i wanted to have my own show which i did
so i was going to continue
being who i was what do you think your
well i think i know what the answer to
this is but i'm always wrong actually
what do you think your greatest
accomplishment is
or was after the age of 50. uh
winning this race no one really thought
that i could win this race and be able
to topple
one of the democratic titans what did
they say about you
they said it's impossible maria i mean
we love you we're not going to give you
a little money but
you will not be able to take her out why
did you run
because of conviction because of
democratic socialism
because we cuban americans we know very
well what that means
misery oppression and exile and i do not
want that for my kids or your kids
when you the naysayers said it's
impossible
how did you answer to that just watch me
you'll see i know my people i know they
will vote for me and i proved it even
20 percent of the democrats hispanic
democrats voted for salazar
being a republican you ran the first
time
and lost correct and were you undeterred
were you i i were you upset i was i was
very upset
but i knew that i didn't know what i was
doing so
uh some of the important people within
the republican party came to me and they
said you can you should do it again and
i'm sure that you have a shot but then
but then we were encountering this
democratic socialism within the
democratic party and
i knew that i stood for the values that
are entrenched in my community
the cuban americans the exile community
the immigrant community of south florida
and i said i can represent them because
they feel like me this is not a mar
this it has nothing to do with political
parties it has to do with your
conviction
conviction and with your love for the
american agenda the american
exceptionality
and that is what we represent and that's
why i won so you did it again
and you won and i won and i love that
you just said
when i said you know were you upset that
you didn't you said no i mean i didn't
know i knew i didn't know what i was
doing
i think women have a hard time sometimes
saying
when they don't know they're they're
afraid of being
you know what okay i'm gonna try again
look at this
absolutely because the american system
gives you the opportunity of trying and
trying and trying hey listen i
interviewed
fidel castro that was really impossible
because i'm the enemy and fidel was
fidel it took me three years
it took me three years of constant
calling and saying i want to interview
him
and they gave they they gave up and they
allow me to interview him that's so
awesome
um you never give up so in this stage of
your career
and especially being over the age of 50
which is the women on this list that
we're looking at and we're celebrating
you um what are
the ways that you might feel more
empowered at this stage in your life do
you think is there a difference
to you at 40 you at 30 you at 20.
i'm wiser i don't sweat the small stuff
i'm kinder i'm more compassionate
i am i'm here for the common good
we're all the same we're on the same
boat rowing towards the same place
no one owns the boat we're all in the
same position
we just have to be kind to each other
and
know that um that life is an experience
and at the end you should not um you
should not resent
you should love more and and raise your
levels of awareness
and know where you're going and have
compassion for the other
who may not know where he or she is
going who may not have those
high levels of awareness who may not
have the compassion who may not have the
wisdom
and that's where i'm at was there a time
before the age of 50
where because you weren't as wise or as
compassionate and sort of
pulled together as you feel at this
stage in your life where maybe
you felt uh i want to give up or i just
i don't know why i can't even kind of
confused crossroads
absolutely what was that like what where
when was that sometimes
in this first 100 days i go what am i
doing here
this is so hard where is the
bipartisanship where is the working
together
i mean is this really the way government
works
but we're here for a purpose but before
the age of 50
in your life was there a time when you
kind of questioned everything and didn't
feel wanted to give up
absolutely many times what can you
having to get made up
every day having to deal with bad
producers having to deal with bad bosses
not
making the money that you thought you
needed to make but
are you describing my career or yours
i've been in television for 35 years
you know what it's like yeah and and
sometimes the bosses and the producers
don't treat us well
and we don't we don't get what we do
what we feel we deserve because we've
worked so hard
day in and day out but you never give up
i'm cuban-american i'm the daughter of
political refugees
you never never never give up
at what point after the age of 50 did
you realize that your hard work
you're never never never giving up had
paid off
and amounted to something all throughout
my career
but after 50 you're asking me yes
specifically for this race
yeah if if i would have not tried it the
second time
i would not be here in front of you
representing my community
listen this is that um this is one of
the
probably the toughest job that i've done
running for congress
most people don't know what a congress
person does
having to travel back and forth not
sleeping in your house
not seeing your family having to
fight with the other party uh not moving
the projects that you think
that are good for for the country
because other people are not
thinking like you are um but it's the
most gratifying
because you're doing it for the common
good you're doing for what you believe
in
so um now i would say that i am at that
point where
i will never give up and hopefully the
voters want me to i will die
doing this for the common good and for
the benefit of the best country on earth
and you know you've heard that i'm sure
the people have heard that phrase
so many times oh america is the best
country on earth
it is indeed and i'm telling you i was a
war correspondent i haven't heard it
enough lately actually so you can keep
saying it oh oh yeah
it's no doubt for years we've been
saying bad things about america
no no no no that's great people
you know the problem is that you do not
understand white if you have not seen
black
and i've seen black many times and
that's why iran
because we may not be perfect but we're
still the best there is
and how do i know that because i've been
on the other side
i have been to every single latin
american country
i i was doing this for 35 years i have
seen what a bat government looks like
and we're not perfect but we're still
the best i love it
how much did you win by almost three
points
10 000 votes 10 000 votes
that must have felt so good
sure but i i i felt it i felt it months
before
yeah but that evening i can share with
you a picture that depicts
that moment i was surrounded by
volunteers i didn't want to invite
anybody no donors or
people from the party important
important
political members i wanted to celebrate
with the people who helped me win
with the volunteers and with the
staffers that were making like five
cents an hour and and then yes
and the whole city no one really could
believe it
no one really could believe that's why
everybody say
or most people say that this was the
biggest upset in the country and i'm
very proud of repeating that
i didn't know that was going to be but
now i
say it over and over again and i go wow
so this picture who were you standing
with
and where did how did you hear you first
had one
it was in florida you know who wins
pretty
that same evening so at 7 20
the first dump came out and i was up
by uh almost one point
so between 7 20 and 8 30
we were waiting for the second and the
third dump but
my political advisors joe palaji who i
have to mention him because he really
helped me win um
he told me i would not want to be in
your opponent's shoes
at this hour and i said we did it
oh um so
i love this because um what wait how old
are you right now
i'm 59. 59. okay so for young women
in their 20s and 30s who are str who are
like
scrambling with their careers they're
asking you for advice they're trying to
you know have kids do whatever do it all
they're rushing
what's your message take it easy
take it easy stay at it
take care of your kids first because
according to
jackie o if you do not raise your
children well
it does not matter what else you do
your kids are first because you don't
want them to come to you later and say
mom you
are never there if you're there is
because you care
there's time for everything in this
country there's time for everything
so and i think i'm a very good example
take it easy
work a little play with your kids be
there
and then once they're 18 or 21 like my
kids are
then you go do the other bigger things
you can only do three things right raise
your kids and have a career you cannot
raise your kids have a career and have a
good night's social life
you got to pick two out of three two out
of three okay i'd take the first two i
guess
but those are the long lasting so the
message to young women is they have a
long runway
you have 40 years 50 years to do many
things
maybe 60. correct or 75. look at nancy
pelosi she's 80.
look where she's at at the helm i'm
looking right at her
all right i got a couple fun questions
to end this this was great um
so um what is the one app you can't live
without
um um let me see
where do you always go on your phone
what app what
i would say uh yes that's the alarm
um i would say um
well have a couple i would say the
wallace do journal
okay the wall street journal app you
like that okay
yeah uh what is the most used emoji
what do you use oh the emojis
which one yeah which one do you think
three little monkeys
the three old monkeys okay i like that
nancy pelosi uses hearts
just fyi oh nancy pelosi what
her favorite emoji is hearts oh okay
yeah
let's i think that she needs to show
more of it
okay what uh oh yeah okay i have word
association for you do you know what
that is like
i'll say a word you tell me what comes
to mind one word
millennials millennials my children
uh martina nicoleta 20 21. okay
okay good um do you like just name one
of these tik tok
instagram snapchat or facebook
uh instagram okay okay okay
uh do you want to be called grandma
um not yet got it okay
um what comes to mind when i say this
word
retirement uh never
do you like landlines uh yes
you hear the people better yeah it's
it's it's yeah
better but that's not better that's for
old people
yeah that's me but the sound the sound
is better exactly that's right
i totally agree thank you maria thank
you so much